dans cet entrepôt des tonnes de graines
de tournesol
partis en fumée les bombardements russes
s'intensifie sur la région de donetsk
moscou poursuit son offensive pour
tenter de prendre le contrôle du donbass
la situation est difficile à l'ess qui
car c'est là que se sont concentrés le
plus grand nombre d'équipements
de formation militaire de bataillon de
la fédération de russie
aussi bien de la fédération de russie
que des séparatistes qui les soutiennent
dans la région de louhansk les russes
cherchent à s'emparer de l'iscid shank
et de severodonezk qui forment à elles
deux une agglomération clé dans le
bassin du donbass d'après le gouverneur
de c02 niet la ville est déjà 70% aux
mains de l'armée russe et il est devenu
impossible d'évacuer les douze mille
civils encore présents les forces de
moscou ont aussi repris leur offensive
sur ce lot viande située à une centaine
de kilomètres plus à l'ouest après nuit
de bombardement cet homme n'imagine même
plus quitter l'aide vous pensez que tu
es ce lorient ce nom
pour aller où
nous n'avons nulle part où aller dans la
ville voisine de cramât tort sq les
habitants semblent eux aussi se résigne
à l'arrivée imminente des soldats russes
qui selon eux n'est qu'une question de
semaines